welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor Steven Pincus a
professor of history at Yale professor
Pincus teaches early modern British and
European history he is the author of
Protestantism and patriotism ideologies
and the making of English foreign policy
1652 1668 and England's Glorious
Revolution 1688 to 89 he has also
published numerous essays on the
cultural political and intellectual
history of early modern Britain today
we'll be talking with Professor Pincus
about his newest book called 1688 the
first modern revolution
welcome professor Pincus so pleased to
be here early in your newest book which
will be out in September you retell in a
significantly new way the story of the
Glorious Revolution
what is the Glorious Revolution so the
Glorious Revolution is an event and
which took place normally in 16 normally
considered to have happened in 1688 and
1689 in England in which the old King
James ii who happened to have been a
catholic was replaced by a new King
William and his wife who became Queen
Mary the second and Queen Mary actually
happened to be the daughter of James the
second and it's after William and Mary
that for example the College of William
and Mary in Virginia is named okay and
what drew you to this topic the story of
England's Glorious Revolution which for
a long time had had come to be seen as
marking England as as perhaps the first
modern nation of the first modern
parliamentary nation was always told as
an English story something in which they
were English causes and narrowly English
consequences and my previous work
convinced me of two things one was that
England very much was part of Europe in
the 17th century as much as as part of
Europe in the 21st century and that
trying to understand developments within
England in a narrowly English context
missed a good part of the story the
second thing that my earlier work
convinced me of was that in the 17th
century merchants and economics were an
increasingly important part of English
political and social life and older
accounts of the Glorious Revolution said
nothing about merchants and nothing
about economics okay so how does your
version of the revolution differ from
what's in the books now the normal story
the ubiquitous story of the Glorious
Revolution is that England's revolution
in 1688 89 was a conservative revolution
a sensible revolution and Unruh volution
Airy revolution something which bears no
resemblance to major revolutions like
the French Revolution the American
Revolution the Chinese Revolution the
Russian Revolution and my argument is
that that's exactly wrong that England's
England's revolution in 1688 89 was in
fact the first modern revolution it was
very much a radically transformative
revolution with everything that came
along with it it was a violent
revolution it was a socially divisive
revolution and it was a revolution which
involved large huge segments of the
overall English population
okay and how did you do your research
well the last major work on England's
Glorious Revolution based on on thorough
archival research was done by thomas
babington macaulay in the second quarter
of the 19th century and it stood to
reason that there was a lot of material
that became available since then and it
turned out they were there was a huge
amount of material so I went visited a
range of European archives I traveled to
local record offices local depositories
of of manuscripts
that had not existed in the 19th century
I visited collections of business
materials which weren't fully available
in the 19th century and I also used the
wealth of materials that had in various
ways made their ways into North American
archives both in Canada and in the u.s.
again which British historians have
traditionally ignored I say so I imagine
that's one of the reasons why the old
narrative has been so widely accepted
for so long are there any other reasons
well the the old narrative was accepted
for a long time because there were a
number of people invested in telling a
story that England was not like the rest
of Europe or like the rest of the world
um so the the key moments of the telling
of the story of England's Revolution of
1688 89 were in 1848 18-49 the period in
which the Europe was convulsed with
revolutions so thomas babington macaulay
was invested in saying that england
wasn't like like these other places on
the continent where there could be a
radical and destructive revolution that
england had what he said was a saving
revolution which prevented it from
having in the 17th century which
prevented it from having a violent
revolution in the 19th century an
earlier moment in which the story was
told was by Edmund Burke when he was
during the revolution the 1789
revolution in France in which he again
said England had a sensible and Glorious
Revolution
whereas France had a violent and
destructive revolution and the final
important phase of the telling of the
story was the 1930s when George McAuley
Trevelyan wanted to distinguish English
political culture from the from the
political culture that was leading to
fascism in Spain and in Italy and to
Nazism in Germany so in all three key
moments the English were invested in
telling a story about themselves which
was to suggest how different they were
from continental Europeans and
in doing your research were there any
any elements that surprised you yeah I
mean I think the biggest surprise was to
discover how important India and the
Empire more broadly was in the run-up
and the causes and in the consequences
of the Revolution so none of the books
about the none of the myriad books about
the the Glorious Revolution say anything
about the fact that James ii declared
war on the Mughal Empire in India in
1687 and that war proved to be a
disastrous failure and how excited and
interested most English people were
about India and the Empire more broadly
and how in fact the revolution of 1688
eighty-nine completely transformed
England's relationship with India and
also with the West Indies and and and
and North America so how was it changed
how was it work so james ii was a very
modern and forward-looking monarch who
thought that england's future as a major
european player could be secured by
creating a massive authoritarian
territorial empire overseas both in the
east indies and what's now India and
Indonesia
and in the West Indies meeting both the
Caribbean and North America so he tried
to consolidate centralize control and
used the revenues from this empire to
finance a huge standing army in England
now England had traditionally been a
place where there was no regular
standing army and James created one of
the most professional and efficient
armies the Europe had seen it had
between forty and fifty thousand men
whereas England traditionally had had an
army of maybe two thousand men so it was
this very sort of strong authoritarian
army which which he which he created
based on this authoritarian Empire
overseas and what happened at the
revolution was to transform the English
Empire the British Empire from being an
authoritarian torrid territorial Empire
into being a commercial empire when
where the emphasis was exclusively on
trade and to
form England itself from an agrarian
society into a manufacturing society
so without the Glorious Revolution in my
view there would have been a very
different British Empire in the 18th and
19th century and without the Glorious
Revolution in the late 17th century
there would have been no Industrial
Revolution in the late 18th and 19th
centuries thank you very much for being
here with us today and we'll look
forward to your book in September okay
it's been a pleasure for more
information about Professor Pincus and
his work please visit our website at
Yale ddu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale